speaking of you ought to know since
we're celebrating a Jagged Little Pill
is that the song we're gonna sing today
it is for you yeah thank you so let's go
back this is the song that really broke
on KROQ radio and suddenly overnight
life's people are singing this song with
you and your audiences are around the
block waiting for you alright here we go
I want you to know that I am happy fear
I wish nothing but the best for you
books I'm not a version of me she
perverted like me she go down on you in
I feed her she speak ethically
would she have your baby I'm sure she
make
salons mothers cuz the love that you
gave that we made wasn't hey let me get
enough for you to be able to I know
every time you speak her name she know
how you told me to hold me until you
died till you died
[Music]
you seem very well seems look peaceful
I'm not quite as well I thought you
should know
did you forget about me
mister do the city I hate to bug you in
the middle of it was a slap in the face
how quickly I was replaced and are you
single night when yeah her is the
love that she gave that me made wasn't
able to make it on before you too boy
no never attorney a sweet honey does she
know how you told me you'd hold me until
you died
[Music]
yeah
cuz the joke that you laid in the bed
that was me I'm not gonna fade as soon
as you close your eyes and you
and every time I stretch my nails down
someone else's back
[Applause]
[Music]
laughs when
but she gave Mary
beautiful